hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the feed a Grand
Prix quarterfinals it's Donald / Sakura
Nakamura and as you've seen both of the
classical games were drawn out they have
to go into tiebreaks this is the second
game of the rapid first game of the
rapid was drawn so it would be very
interesting to see how this turns out
and who will advance to the semi-finals
of the Fida grand prix 2019
now before we check out the game we do
have a nice photo of the two of them
shake shaking hands compliments of Nicky
Riga there you have it and yeah let's
let's enjoy the game so like we said
dubov has the white pieces and he opens
with c4 perhaps influenced by by Magnus
Carlsen as he has I want some very nice
game with the English opening lately
with E 5 by Nakamura
Nights the c3 will Knight to f6 Knight
to f3 and now Knight to c6 the four
Knights variation of the English we have
g3 dubov precursor Finn Couture the
light square bishop d5c captures and d5
Knight captures and e5 and of course a
bishop to Jeju and now avoiding trade
with tonight to b6
we have castles by dubov and now comes
the Bishop to e7 and Carlson had this
position against Apollo in Dakota war
blitz section of the tournament that we
covered III believe some few days ago
but cousin played a three in this
position here do both plays a different
idea he goes b3 and prepares the fee and
cathode the dark square bishop as well
so deviating from the concent Apollo's
game with castles by Nakamura Bishop to
b2 now rook to e8 and now comes Luke the
c1 just nicely developing pieces Bishop
to f8
and it's not a new line or anything it
was played plenty of times d3
there are 22 games just in 2019 where
this exact same position happened so
nice the d4 by Nakamura with III either
pushing the knight back or going for
this straight Knight captures with Queen
captures on f3 and now just c6 taking
away the b5 and the d5 squares from
White's night with rook after the one
and now Queen to g5 and here there there
is one game
2006 word Quinta e 2 was played but here
Du Bois plays H 4 it's a new move and it
is as of this moment move 15 that we
have a completely new game so here a
Nakamura has to decide as he want to go
g6 does he want to go east 7 but he goes
Queen to g4 and offers a queen trade we
have night Stewie for by dubov Queen
captures on f3 just rating Queen's
Bishop captures and now a5 preparing a
for with night to c5
now a for nonetheless we have d4 by
white and now a capture Sun b3h after
some d3 and now look to a 2 already
Nakamura against a lot of activity with
the rook getting the bishop out of the
way with the ship the c3 ends now comes
Knight to d5 and here your bishop is
under attack you already moved it on the
previous move you don't really have a
good Square to move it to let's say you
go Bishop d2 you know try to control the
night here not really something you want
to do just Bishop captures and c5 d
captures and now efore you push the
bishop back and it's hard to say where
you're gonna put the bishop back if you
go back up to g2 then Bishop to g4 is
just deadly and you have to move the
rook but you can't if you move the rules
and you're going to lose the bishop so
you will basically lose the exchange so
after a four you'd have to go to the
shrub e 2 and then well you know your
Bishop is again stuck here you can move
it as well the rook is just very strong
here so do book doesn't like any of this
he doesn't want to move the bishop here
rather gives up the other bishops
so butter up characters on d5 he gives
up the bishop paired with C captors on
d5 and out Knights the d3 cutting
pressure towards the e5 square and here
nakamura can choose either he will go F
or or he will try something else here
first he develops the blusher we have
Bishop to g4 attacking the rook here
rook to d2 offering a trade also he
doesn't want a Nakamura's rook to stay
so active for for very long with rook
captures Bishop captures and now
nakamura doesn't like efore then you
give a DF for square to do bhavas night
there is a well f6 is an option nakamura
obviously isn't you know an f6 guy so he
plays eek actress on d4 with
with the next idea with ecat force on d4
and now Russia back to f5 pressuring the
night-nights the c5 now attacking the b7
pawn and here is Nakamura's idea he just
grabs a lot of activity rook to e2
attack is the Bishop Bishop to e3 and
not look to be too and now b6 is
definitely the idea you want to remove
the defender of the b3 pawn so dubov
might as well capture the pawn with nice
cap for some b7 rook captures and b3 and
now just Knight back to c5 attacking the
rook rook the before and now comes Luke
to a-1 just grabbing hold of the open a
file and now finally f6 it seems
Nakamura is now an f6 guy with rook to
e8 now dubov zero gets a lot of activity
King to f7 unpinning and now just work
the d8 trying to grab this rope from
behind the point we have Bishop to e7 a
very nice move a genius idea of my
Nakamura he attacks the rook and gives a
white an option so what do you do here I
want you to pause the video here and
decide what to do do you want to move
the rook where do you want to move it to
do do you want to capture the d5 pawn
what's what's your plan
so I feel free to pause the video and
try to you know decide whether you want
to capture it or not I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
did decide to capture the pawn
congratulations you have found the move
that to do both played but unfortunately
it's not the best line it seems to be
that the pawn is poisoned but it's not
it's not all that easy to see why it's
poisoned best would be just to run away
as far away as possible
with the rug but do of capture that we
have look after Sun d5 and now comes a
Nakamura's idea why did he allow all of
this Bishop to c8
and now you see the problem here of
course you have to move the bishop as it
was under attack but the idea is next
you want to go here you want to go to b7
not now but the night is still in c5 but
let's say White has to play something
rook to be 1 check is coming so let's
say what do you want to play you don't
want to allow rook to b5 if rook to b5
then Bishop to e6 will trap the rook
because then the knight will not be able
to move
because rook captures rook so here if
you try something like 93 attack the
rook now you get this line rugby one
check and now you have to block with the
night night to see one and then just
Bishop to a3 will we need the game
there's no way to protect the night you
have to play rook to c5 and give up the
exchange in this way and it's just gonna
be a much better much better game for
black there's really no no good
compensation here for for the exchange
and of course if you just move the King
let's say King here then Bishop the b7
is the plan now that the knight has
moved and you will again lose this
exchange you have to go night at 4 and
give up the rook if you move it then of
course look to h1 it's checkmate one of
the one of the poisons Nakamura brought
to this game so here you don't really
have a good way of doing this you don't
want to allow Ruby one trick so the King
has to run away kink the f1 by do both
but now rook the b5 and now you know
that Bishop to e6 traps the rook and
there's no way to avoid this duo just
said ok I'm just gonna try and increase
the activity of my King Bishop to e6 now
of course you have to capture we have
Knight captures on e6 rook captures on
d5 and now just Knight back to c5 so
here do both did grab a pawn but he is
down the Nandi exchange but still
nothing is lost I mean he Nakamura still
has to work very hard for his meal
so first f5 taking away the e4 square
from White's Knight also preventing
further expansion on the Kings side we
have Knight 2 D 3 and now Bishop to d6
King to f3 bringing the King into the
game Bishop the c7 now sorry about that
Knight to f4 attacking the rook and the
rook to a5 getting the rook as far away
as possible from the night you don't
it's a rapid game you know you don't
want to always have to check whether
this night will for pure rook and King
Knights the e2 and now comes a rook to
a3 I'm just pinning that Bishop we have
nice to a4 and now comes look to be
three nights the d5 attacking the bishop
and now Bush up the b8
Knight back to f4 and now Bush up to a 7
already threatening to win the d4 pawn
as you can see that the bishop is pinned
so King to e2 unpinning and now road
back to a3 with nice the d3 and now
comes King to e6 Nakamura
now starts to bring his King into the
game night at four check with King 2d6
night to h5 going after the g7 pawn g6
pushing the night back and now comes in
Bishop to b6 now with the idea of
bringing the bishop over to to the f6
square we have king to d2 and now comes
King to c6 King to e2 back and now but
King back to d6 Nakamura also trying to
figure out a way how to how to improve
his position King to d2 Bishop back to
d8 now the bishop will be ready to to
support the advance of the Jeep on we
have King to e2 and now Bishop to f6 as
planned
King back to DT we have King to c6 and
now King to e to do both has the hope he
can grab a draw out of this game and
continue into into the faster rapid
games King to b5 now with h5 and now the
bishop is nicely placed here judge g5
pushing the knight back with Knights to
d5 attacking the bishop and now again
before b8 just controlling the the
squares that the knight can go to we
have Bishop to D 2 now and now rook to
e7 King Tubby 3 rook to d7 now attacking
the knight Knight back to a 3 and now
rook to f7 defending the pawn here we
have Knight to c4 trying to win the rook
with Knight to d6 check and now Nakamura
just moves the troop to a faith we have
knight back to e5 and Bishop to e7 now
we have F 3 and now rook to e8 y
Nakamura Knights to f7 and now with a
double attack towards the g5 pawn but
here just rook to a3
this comes with check King to e2 and
here King to c4 Nakamura now
pushes back the white king and grabs
more space in the center with his own
king with Bishop captures on g5 and Hiro
Nakamura doesn't grab the pawn
immediately he says there's time for
this later I just want to keep my bishop
into the game Bishop to b4 we have
Knight to e5 check came to d5 and now
Knight back to d3 attacking the bishop
rook a to check with King to f1 so the
King has now been pushed all the way to
the back rank and I'll just rush up to
d2 are offering a trade of dark square
Bishop Bishop to have six defending the
d4 pawn but now King to c4 attack
the night and now you don't really have
a good square for your night if you go
night 2 f2 then Bishop to e3 will be
strong with a double attack against the
night and the d4 pawn so we're gonna win
the point either way and any other
squares are not all that great for the
night so here
dubov goes for Knight to e5 check King
captures on d4 and now fortunately for
Nakamura there are no nasty discoveries
available for the white knight
so g4 we have Bishop to f4 now with a
double attack against the night here
Knight to g6 this comes with check King
to e3 and the knob Knights to h4 with F
capture Sun g4f captures on g4 and now
h6 preventing g5 King to G 1 by 2 above
and here there are a few ways to wealth
to continue playing this game even feel
free to pause the video and try to try
to finish this game with black try to
find the nicest way to win this game for
Nakamura I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent winner of of winning games and
for those who just won't enjoyed show
one possibility is Bishop to g5 this is
the engines favorite just offering a
trade or to win a knight now either
white will trade or you will go Knight
a5 check King to f3 going after the g4
pawn and now after Bishop to g7 you all
seem to start picking up the pawns here
and it's a game over this is the Angels
favorite but it's not Nakamura's
favorite if you found a bishop 2h to
check then you have also found the move
nakamura played and it is also just as
winning and much nicer if I might add so
here you have the option of going king
h1 or you can go King f1 king h1 is a is
a tougher defense but it also it's not
really enough Bishop to b8 now go
threatens rook to HQ checked which would
be very strong and if you try something
like King g1 just try and repeat moves
then you get Bishop to e7
now you threaten some nasty discoveries
with your king and after g5 you will go
king to a4 check King to f1 and now H
captures on g5 this would be very
unfortunate if you actually did this
because then h6 pawn is very strong so
instead you don't capture you just go
King to g4 and now you have to see this
line all the way until the end but it's
very hard that's why it most likely
dubov decided not to go for it
g6 and now look to F to check King t1
rook captures on f6 now g7 noticed that
there is no good way to prevent the pond
from queening but there is one good way
rook the e6 check use this check the
riemann over the rook king d2 and now
look to e8 you prevented the pond from
twinning and now of course it's a
completely winning game so after this
Bishop to HD check do both did not go
for rook to a king to h1 he instead went
King to f1 but this is just much worse
as we are deprived from this beautiful
line that we've just seen so Nakamura
just wait Luke you have to check of
course now you lose just lose the bishop
here we have king teti 1 and here
nakamura just played rook captures on f6
and it was in this position that Donald
was resigned the game end with this
resignation he is also knocked out of
the feeder Grand Prix 2019 so excellent
victory for Nakamura who continued to
the semi-finals and already today we had
the two games that have been played in
the semifinals of the feeder Grand Prix
both of them were drawn and Nakamura
drew again against Alexander II shook
where a lot of people were saying that
there was so much more to the game I
know it seems like a very fast draw but
you know who are we were we to argue you
know about the day making draws early
and also we had the other pair young
Pony versus rather Slovak also ended in
a draw so we will see tomorrow if there
classful and in classical or will they
also go to rapid tie breaks and also
here we have a nice photo of Nakamura
taking a selfie with this young
gentleman here and I also just wanted to
point out that this is the correct way
to take a selfie
you should always hold your smartphone
horizontally not vertically because then
the photo will be usable on all
platforms you know so don't don't ruin
the photo by taking a selfie vertically
you know photos are forever and
instagrams and and you know platforms
like that or not so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it do check out the
chess clock first thing in the
description will be the link to the
application on Google Playstore give us
you know some tips how to improve it and
what we can change or add and you know
feel free to join our beta testing team
yeah I would like to thank hardmode
Keller and Alexandra Wilson for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
I think all for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the feeder Grand Prix
coverage and while checking up on your
suggestions and and whatnot thank you I
will see you soon have an excellent rest
of your day